67 مليون هذا هو عدد الاطفال الذين حرموا
من حقهم في التطعيم في العالم بين عامي
2019 و 2021
انتكاسه للجهود العالميه من اجل حقوق
الاطفال هي الاكبر منذ 30 عاما بحسب اخر
تقرير لمنظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
جائحه كوفيد انهكت النظم الصحيه العواقب
توقف تطعيم الاطفال في كل مكان في العالم
تقريبا
افريقيا هي المنطقه الجغرافيه التي يوجد
بها اكبر عدد من الاطفال غير الملقحين بما
يقارب 13 مليونا لاسيما في نيجيريا
واثيوبيا في العام الماضي ارتفع عدد
الاطفال المصابين بالشلل بعد تعرضهم لشلل
الاطفال بنسبه 16% مقارنه بعام 2021
وتضاعفت حالات عدوى الحسبه خلال نفس
الفتره
التقرير الذي جاء تحت عنوان حاله الاطفال
في العالم لسنه 2023 التطعيم لكل طفل اشار
الى فقدان الثقه في التطعيم باكثر من 11%
في فرنسا واكثر من 33% في غينيا الجديده
وعان والسنغال واليابان
البيانات الجديده اكدت ان الصين والهند
والمكسيك هي البلدان الوحيده التي حافظت
على تصورات ايجابيه لمساله تطعيم الاطفال
كما عرفت انظمتها تقدما في هذا المجال